hello I'm live if anyone happens to get
this we don't premiere these and we
don't announce these we just go live and
see what happens
it'd be fun to do a drunk livestream one
of these days John loved a drunken live
stream I'm trying to just fill in the
time before people come in we got one
like here that means we got someone here
who has not said anything in the chat
yeah we got 24 eyes on us 24 eyes on us
what's up
oMG Jordan green boy Jenna Jenna
Randolph haven't heard from you in a
long time get James jasmine papaya
pictures what kind of films do you make
there so one if you guys don't know what
dope what's up guys Amy be easy
where are you everyone misses you oh
gosh okay
so Cesar this is all gonna do I'm just
going to say people's names we're not
actually gonna talk about anything so
what we're gonna do
what's a hello Carter Brandon Brittney
Lange hey good to see you again good to
see you again so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna reveal the next dope trope
and in case you guys don't know what the
dope trope is that is basically tropes
or repeated things that we see in movies
that were sick of work that they just we
just noticed they happen you know so
that's what we're gonna start off with
then we're gonna open up the forum here
to whatever q and A's you guys have so
John I noticed that you have added on to
this special dope trope notepad that I
have created and I haven't read any of
your dope tropes yet I wanted you to
just surprise me so John give us the
fourth dope trope okay ever notice how
in action movies action heroes are super
amazing ever notice that
that thing we're like an action hero
stops a knife like just right before it
hits their eye and like every action
hero is able to get it right at that one
point which is cool but I'm like it's
it's so used now that all these guys
can't be that good that is true
that's a good one that's a good dope
truck that's a good dope truck John it's
a good dope truck you have learned
wisely how to identify a dope true like
one of those guys got to get stabbed
you like these life thank you for liking
these live streams so I found out that
YouTube's doing some weird thing where
they're not gonna have us be verified
anymore and they're doing this to a lot
of creators some people will still be
verified I don't know how to remain
verified but apparently that's gonna
affect the notification bail process
which is just great della of course you
can suggest that shirt and trap dawg I
have five shirts i fluctuate between
I'll have you know it's more than just
this one shirt but guys let's talk about
some movie news catch us up it's been a
while since we've done a live stream so
help us help us out with something here
greg has tee shirt has one shirt you
know what maybe I'm gonna Bart Simpson
this this is gonna be my one outfit that
I wear all the time for the rest of the
year Fiji yeah you guys control this
livestream so we just need to know do we
need something to talk about leaked
footage of the Joker has been spreading
around recently be careful to react to
it got to react to it screw it let's
cover it yeah burn that bridge Warner
Brothers ruin it right away oh wait we
got della who has submitted a dope
trophy the bad guy gets caught on
purpose yes there is common good catch
that is common it's it's more of like a
plot point nowadays you know what I mean
[Music]
yeah well I feel like a big blockbusters
off and like kind of start to notice
what each other are doing and then you
know bane and then you got all these
Joker even before that everyone wants to
get water
okey dokey I did hear about Tom Welling
I was just on
SJ news and I learned it about it while
I was there like a nod during their
livestream that Tom Welling is set to
reprise as Clark Kent enroll in the next
crossover of the arrow verse I'm excited
for this because if it was crisis on I
don't know what that which one it is you
want you guys will correct me so yeah I
mean I'm catching up on arrow currently
I'm halfway through season seven I just
finished episode one of the I finally
got to the cross the the Elseworlds the
crossover portion word in season seven
of arrow occurs because I know arrows
ending and I want to be able to be fully
caught up in and I want to be able to
watch the final episode with the rest of
the world so yeah with Tabo but Tom
Welling returning John are you excited
about this talk a lot about it today
yeah so excited for Tom Welling to be
back mostly because I've been wondering
for years if he's still around what is
he doing I mean like past the fog remake
I've heard hide nor hair of Tom Welling
so I'm just glad he's alive he's like
brick every actor who plays Superman I'm
just glad when they come back to the
screen at all ya know like Brandon's
around with I'm always like oh good for
him I mean Brandon Rath is gonna be in
it so Tom Welling in the Elseworlds
you know what we gotta go over some of
these dope jokes you're committing like
in this er I'm noticing it's interesting
doing live streams we have to read and
talk simultaneously so with Tom Welling
coming back I remembered that in the
Elseworlds of the episode I just watched
when they cut to I just watched this
last night and then the story happened
to premiere the they cut to the world or
wherever earth supergirls on cara's on
and then they cut to the Kent farm and
they start playing the Smallville theme
song you know
CW songs are good what happened to a
good CW or WB's on the Austin's Creek
was monumental at all so yeah them and
they and they cut to that I got excited
because I only watched up to season 5 of
Smallville and then I watched the last
like 10 minutes of the whole show just
because I heard all the crimes people
were having with how they handled the
Superman suit and I just wanted to see
what everyone was talking about so yeah
I'm still excited then I hope he's
rocking the suit I'm
hope he's rocking the suit and yeah
Michael Rosenbaum that would be I hope
they don't spoil that I'll be sorry
I literally got John feel that classic
nipple you know the thought of Michael
Rosenbaum returning as Lex live yes I
have actually I've seen a few episodes
so you know who Michael Rosenbaum is
yeah he's awesome so if they if they had
in return but they don't reveal that to
the media and it's just a surprise when
you watch it that would be killed I'd be
more easily yeah I hate to admit it I'm
be a little bit huh you know I love to a
minute I'd be more excited about that
then I would be who it's all well I
think but I'd be more excited Tomlin
returns in a Superman stick but how
excited would you be if Christie cruet
came back oh man yes she's Asian like
Asian girls and men and I like Persian
guys and Armenian girls and Serbians
what's up to our Serbian viewers next we
commented a Serbian transsexuals
whatever yes
this videos family-friendly so John I'm
only friendly move on to another
question a second but what give us the
dope get another dope find fun one at
the dope truck dude Carter Lovejoy says
we know Carter right yeah yeah shoots in
the air and lets the bad guy get away
kind of like Point Break that sort of
weather mad oh wait that reminds me of
another dope I can't reveal but it's
linked that's kind of like my other dope
trope that I forgot to write down mad at
beer dude first super channel the doings
Matt beer you're already a patron and
here you are I hope you empty your bank
account today just on these super chats
and then ask for a refund and while Co
what you think this is yeah you can have
a refund sure okay so did you get what's
uh what's what's going on John get us a
question give us a question Adam Sandler
has been getting a lot of buzz on his
performance and uncut gems do you think
he could secure an Oscar nomination for
it
I don't think the Academy likes Adam
Sandler enough and from what I hear
about the Adam Sandler portrayal there
it's just a dramatic performance of what
he kind of already does just angry and
yelling a lot it's like watching funny
people being like this is I you know
he's being really real but I have a
sense he's being kind of real yeah yeah
like I'm kind of impressed but also I
think he just let go I asked whether you
guys are into Star Trek that's how I
tell you Catan reads that it's funny to
me because of the way how sometimes in
people comment this is my tone is so
important in communication because the
way some people comment I'm like are
they mad beer a gammon here exhausts me
thanks guys what's up look at those you
guys are the best patrons right here Jon
flip your hair that's what they want to
see that's what they want to see so um
well Star Trek fans what Star Trek I've
seen half of the movies some of the
Sherriff glimpses of the show and lots
of things that very much April yes we'll
move on to the super chests in just a
second but I wanted to say that yeah
bill hader better win for directing one
of my I was just talking with a perk
Michael be a person on our patreon page
Omni media check his channel out he was
just taught
I was talking with him about no no it
wasn't Michael because Christmas may you
that's another new channel um Chris May
of telling him how berry season 2
there's an episode with a little girl
it's almost say there's only one episode
that whole show a girl and if Bill Hader
does not win for directing that I will
be very upset because I don't know if
Barry's one of my favorite shows of all
time just yet I can't make that
statement yet however that is one of the
best episodes the television I have ever
seen and if you guys watch Barry you
know exactly what episode I'm talking
about okay so what did what are the
horsemen wants to know that beer for
Pete you by the way sorry YouTube won't
refund you the super chaplain you can
always try a Tyler good ear from your
body buddy Tyler Haig okay Eric horseman
did either of you ever watch penny
dreadful are you going
watch the prequel do you know what the
I'm talking about law
have you seen penny dreadful I've seen a
few episodes over your shoulder when we
used to live and I was I know a lot of
people who loved it and I was honestly
very surprised by the tone because it's
a lot more pulpy and melodramatic than I
expected
oh yeah man of course it is they're
dealing with like Frankenstein I thought
it was gonna be like well I think it
used to it is but it is kind of it's got
a hide in tone for sure man Eva Green is
insanely great in that show same great
and also bond - don't do this Alton yeah
Timothy Dalton isn't credit that dude is
an underrated actor there are so many
shows that have ended such a long time
ago that I'm catching up I'm only
halfway through the season to a penny
dreadful and the and the and the world I
just finished my girlfriend show me
Spartacus and I watched the first season
of that it's fun because the first three
episodes were like cheesy was really
entertaining and then the show just gets
super super gripping just like you don't
want to stop it it's so good and people
always talked about the amount of her
you already get demonetised imagine the
amount a sex on a game of Thrones
family-friendly size where families are
having sex with a child locked away from
your eyes when they're kept in the car
with air conditioning yes so the
Spartacus that show has Oh much like
constant there's like literally just
like whoa this is like a full-on or D
yeah it's pretty pretty gnarly sex with
the Romans
though it's an easy way to go we could
be historical cuz what they really did
they threw up in public places and the
oil sex yeah
Oh Tyler it's so good to hear from you
buddy
Oh Tyler Hague we have a couple of
friends moving in Wisconsin and we are
planning on visiting them because they
are two of my closest friends hey Matt
Matt beer has seen Spartacus it's good
here gonna start up the next one here so
John pull us another question we got so
many questions I want everyone to know
no one is intentionally ignored we just
kind of move at random here all right
super question let's flexure okay what
are we going into super isn't it do you
know well I mean David 3x wants to know
thank you for your for your love and do
you know that Saved by the Bell is
getting a reboot I just heard this
because of the peacock right cuz of NBC
I'm not what you call have you seen
caesium most olives the originals not
ecology do you know what the plot is of
the new show yeah no I forget all the
characters names but dude but it just
says Seder don't ask the way they're
talking about the show they sound like
they want to deal with some like
real-life issues they did that once
every 20 episodes but they like know
what the plot setup of it you know like
Saved by the Bell does some pretty
ridiculous stuff like ridiculous things
that happen in it are so not realistic
and but then what they talked about if
anyone it was the plot just um you know
yeah - I put a link there so we can just
read it they should just borrow from the
actors real lives you know cuz like the
guy who played screech like he's how
kinds of like you know public yeah
problems and stuff and he could like
learn through it on national - oh we got
tickets to go watch ad astra later
tonight we we're gonna aim to catch last
blood really quick let me just throw it
out there what would you rather have a
review of because it will it's kind of a
crazy because the friends are going out
of town so we're trying to spend time
there's are two of our best friends and
so it's kind of a crazy region we don't
know if we'd have time to get a review
up but if we had to choose between an ad
astra review or a last blood review
which ones would you guys
prefer a poll would be easier but also
see what you guys are saying here right
now is a review cats Hey
are you excited for the mandalorian or
Watchmen ooh
mandalorian Watchmen I'm just so like it
looks really good but I just don't know
it's gonna it's never gonna be more edgy
and more compelling in that department
but at the same time Mandalorian it's
just bottom line I've seen three
trailers four Watchmen one trailer for
the Mandalorian that easily the
Mandalorian trailer there's the one that
maybe go difference between having one
show that is being built upon this like
very revered bedrock where is like the
Mandalorian basically just has to do
right by the concept right and like
since it director is directing flash how
about Bill Hader or Bill skarsgård for
reverse-flash what do you think gee uh
Bill Hader or Bill scar scar for
reverse-flash I would say Bill Hader
I don't know Bill skarsgård playing
another bag it will be good for Bill
skarsgård too it might be a good Janerio
[Laughter]
like with I think it would be a good
transition roll for Bill skarsgård
reunited with the director of end with
any machete at the director of it and
then also playing another villain but
this time you get to see his face I
think that would actually be a good
transitional role for him you know I
think sometimes actors make the mistake
of trying to swing into another role
when really if you especially if you
break out in movies it's best to like
make transitional steps with your films
and and I feel like that actually will
be a better but I'd be more excited
about Bill Hader honestly but I think it
would be better opportunity perhaps for
Bill skarsgård because at the moment he
is just you know penny wise and the
brother of all the others to mix up
what's Jasmin's quit Thank You jasmine
thanks so much Jimmy wants to know
you guys hear about YouTube's so-called
update it's called destroying hopes and
dreams all I know is they got rid of
stuff that makes content creative very
well creative and sounds more verses you
read no is this the does this have to do
with the whole verification thing I mean
yeah I know the verification thing has
led to a lot of issues and yeah
different like channel guidelines about
like what constitutes you to be a
full-on YouTube partner or whatever yeah
I'll look it up I'm just hearing the
news things are changing light today I
know the most common thing out of all
the YouTube problems that are always
present itself is that we usually bring
up the yellow dollar bill signs because
that just never makes sense to me
um for the most part it doesn't the
concept doesn't but like the way they
decided go about it that's what bothers
me right this is the funny I hear
someone and it's this I haven't heard of
it I'm gonna tell you like why you might
we'll see if we end up talking about
this more but thanks for informing us
jasmine I I noticed that in YouTube
circles and I'm sure like it's like this
with a lot of professions is that when
you're around other youtubers most
people kind of just complain about
what's wrong with YouTube right that
seems to be the main topic of
conversation and I noticed this channel
continues to grow and stays better if my
mind or like our dynamic is just not
primarily focused on the yeah yeah say
we should so we like will open up about
we're like a yellow dollar bill sign
especially pisses like when Lady and the
[ __ ] got it yeah issues because it's
like a lot of times you these issues
that YouTube creates there's usually
ways to work around them and sometimes
it takes a lot of figuring out but
they're people may it happen I mean a
youtuber that I if you guys haven't seen
it's channels that three million subs
now there's a youtuber that we met in
Mexico called dead meet James
and he blew up in the middle of ad
pocalypse like right when ad pocalypse
began started a brand new channel and
it's not 2 million yes just a million a
year when everyone was like you can't
make money on YouTube you can't do well
on YouTube you can't do this on YouTube
and when I was talking with him the next
year he didn't know about most of what I
was talking with him about hilarious so
yeah there is a conversation to be a
part and I'm like yeah I was like oh and
it really hit me when I was talking with
him of wow I remember when we started up
when this channel began I didn't really
know much about YouTube honestly it's
like didn't really watch that many
channels I didn't really know much I
didn't follow a channel like I saw I
would watch Jeremy John's a little more
consistent than everyone else but didn't
really follow a channel so we just just
did our own thing and then it flew up
and I was like cool and then the more
you get involved we start learning all
these weird protocols they keep shifting
yeah but I noticed that the less you
it's like you got to be aware of it to
work around it well yeah and it's like
you know the further you get into
anything just the more details you
become aware of and yeah the thing I
have you know as I am learning what the
art of business is like one thing I've
tried to hold on to is the Zen that no
matter which field you're in or what
you're doing there will be challenges
you don't have direct control over that
you have to get creative to subvert
exactly so I try when YouTube does
something weird I try to be like it's
okay yeah this happens to every business
yeah we get a we get annoyed at first
and then yeah yeah cuz you have to cuz
you got to let that out cuz it's you
know it's a wrecking ball in the middle
of your day
yes blind wave and the normies are
wonderful wonderful reaction channels
Lynnae shouts ow she says burn it down
oh damn chilli Pennywise yeah that's the
matchup we need I love that shirt I
really do love that shirt yeah man I can
talk I mean we love oh it was a lot of
youtubers that we watched so many
youtubers that we actually want warm
definitely more than ever in my entire
life but while John looks for the next
question
yeah would dead meet Jay I didn't want
to mention that with like dead meat was
a big inspiration because you got to
think there's so much you gotta be aware
of what makes his story so fascinating
to a lot of youtubers
wai-wait he's white a white man made in
America no it's not that is it's like
yeah the ad pocalypse Kurt's sure but
then what were all the restrictions that
came with it so many more people and of
course we deal with it cuz we do
reactions of the copyright claims the
content claims and then also the yellow
dollar bill signs which is primarily
because of violence or sexual stuff
included in the video and he is doing a
segment called killcount which is filled
with like so much of the movies and
sometimes like sexual stuff revolved
around and of course and like all the
things that people are complaining about
and he managed to kill it saundra he's
recently engaged like he's and to me
that's inspiring so it's good to be
reminded of like there are people who
manage to find it's like he don't talk I
don't want I don't know how much of the
behind-the-scenes stuff he reveals but
of course he has like some of the issues
that we deal with but he has learned to
work around them basically and I and I
am and to me like I haven't talked to
him in such a long time but that when I
my time spent the limited time we have
with him and Mexico it has greatly
impacted me a lot so yeah much this
wife's dream is mainly about dead meet
James go watch his chamber their podcast
Britney Lange thank you so much for the
love that is a very good say she said
that we're on her list of top guys
tubers are awesome and you're on my
table so youtubers I want to meet on day
one day 19 one day do you have any
advice to someone who is nervous and
started their own channel I want to
start a woman I'm super scared to don't
do it no one can make it don't listen to
this whole thing about dead mean James
perfect tail slate to that question I
wish I saved the dead me James talk for
for this question because that would be
a perfect answer for you I I guess like
the the best thing you got to do is and
this can be hard because in the
beginning of building a channel you
really want to read
as many comments as possible and reply
to as many people as possible at the
same time you gotta remembered that you
don't want to try to it's like doing
content that is similar like we do
reactions and pyro mag discovers this is
a kind of video everyone covers in this
reaction field similar kind of videos
sure but you gotta also maintain what
makes you unique and know try to emulate
other people's personalities that's why
I don't like to do this by think you
know part of the fun of starting out
your own channel and part of the process
of finding your own voice anyway is
trying things out and entertaining your
fantasies and the kinds of things you
would want to create are the things that
you're not seeing that you would like
and so I would say you know embrace that
and you know mess around and try stuff
you know what I would also well you know
what money's to worry I don't really
have anything to add on to that I think
it's ain't too much everyone's gonna be
give me some Bharti hey cats
stop arguing stop that tonic copper
James Cormier how do you think Nolan
thank you first of all and how do you
think no one's new film tenant will do
there's rumors it's a sequel to
Inception oh if he did like a Shyamalan
thing with that good question or sequel
yeah oh that would be so cool that would
be the way I get excited for an
inception sequel some crazy surprise
like that ah I would and I seems like
somebody who could I haven't heard that
rumor this is the first I've heard that
would be neat though all I've heard
about Tennant is is some kind of action
movie right I hear like spy thriller and
from people who saw that I haven't seen
the trailer but for people who saw the
trailer they said that it has a little
bit of tone that seems reminiscent of
something like Inception yeah yeah
that's what it is you might call that
Christopher Nolan's style yeah
oh really quick back Britney what I
wanted to also say it like the reason I
brought up comments is because a lot of
times you know there are people like get
me James who still read every single
comment my brother Jay
pick away reads like every comment and
then you got to be a little bit careful
though too sometimes when you get
addicted to comments you try to morph
yourself to only satisfy it has to be a
balance for you just feel like it's like
there are some days I feel like I'm just
super goofy right now and I'm just a
little bit more direct and
straightforward you just got be willing
to be comfortable and be your sail but
you're say hey someone's talking you
directly about their John double toe so
we're doing a live show in LA you going
to it I just heard about this today and
if I you know if the time is free I will
certainly try and be there cuz I that is
probably my longest running like you
know internet show that I've followed
you know I found them spill calm back in
high school and I'm just kind of kept up
ever since so I would love a chance to
go see them live I saw him
Alexander Robertson our friend I don't
know if he's on it but he definitely
went to the studio who took a photo
there may be a to jump in the Bailey
Nyami yeah maybe not we got to go visit
Austin and then go crash their studio
great thumbnails oh thanks
I would love to cuz i chat with whenever
sammy from double toasted his out here
he always hits me up and comes on the
channel so it would be cool to visit
texas one day and you know be able to
try going double toasted we did burst
them in their first showdown match one
question we always get down with one
question that moments why we haven't
been there forever dr. penny 233 we had
people get back to us that the Jurassic
world short film they got theirs blocked
so I tested us I tested ours out yeah it
got blocked but ya know so no we can't
because it's blocked world why I think
Tyrone did one of those sync ups but
I've already watched it and there's
audio in the background I can't get rid
of it this out unfortunately not oh snap
did y'all see three from hell didn't
y'all name your channel after the
Devil's Rejects fortune
I couldn't go but John tell them your
opinion uh-huh chewing on this movie and
what I'll say is this at the moment I
think it's a sequel to The Devil's
Rejects I don't necessarily think it's
the sequel to The Devil's Rejects so if
you are married to the Ark of those
first two films which is beautiful in
some way I would say you don't
necessarily have to see through hell I
do think it has some really great acting
some really great camera work some
really great aura and tone all the
things that Rob Zombie's truly great at
all the visual stuff is awesome there
are parts of the movie I like a lot and
there are parts the there are complaints
that I just understand I'm like it
doesn't feel quite essential and it does
kind of feel like a hangout movie in a
way you know so in my Rob Zombie fanatic
opinion it's all right it's really
arguably not it's not like a definitive
like oh [ __ ] this is the follow-up like
this is it's it's just a way it could
have gone to me not like this is when
the stamp on top of it you know I don't
know but I'd be curious to hear some
other opinions
do we Joe Rogan podcast yeah III listen
to a good I saw Joe Rogan live reason I
live my girlfriend never been to the
comedy store in LA where Joe Rogan often
performs went there recently I was just
about to mention you epic voice guy
because someone asked what our favorite
voice actors are I was gonna say only
epic voice guy so and Kevin Conroy camel
too you know anyone from Batman
animators Joe Rogan I saw him perform
live at The Comedy Store him and Kristy
Elia back to back those two back in the
back it's a hell of a comedy show right
there man face-off remake no you just
remake it with Travolta and make a
choice survive if that would be so
awesome no because of where they're at
no actually that is the best idea
I have heard oh that is the best idea
I've heard for it cuz you can't possibly
recast that face on I love that and
they're like in John Travolta just did
the fanatic which I'm dying to see yeah
yeah the fanatic is one of those movies
I listen to all of Chris Tuckman's to
walk hello T I can't see that hillock
really walk pretty hilarious or whatever
oh yeah you guys don't talk about watch
besides I listened to his whole review
it was like of course it's a giant
spoiler filled review and it's still one
of those really like well now I still
just want to watch it but it's one of
those kind of movies you're like I don't
care what the supposes kind of want to
watch it now so yeah I think John
Travolta to be perfect Nic Cage oh that
would be cool yeah I don't think you
should remake face off yeah do with
women women I feel like that's the
laziest way to approach in titration in
Hollywood I feel like if you did some
kind of now know people hate this I know
people will hate this
but remember 21 Jump Street when that
was announced and people were like why
are they why would you do that that
won't work you know people know that
wouldn't work and then they made it
self-aware they made it meta and they
made it a comedy and I feel like if he
did that with face off you could
potentially work if you still made it
like a cool action comedy if he and you
made fun of like they haven't seen it
yeah I've seen glimpses on TNT over the
years but I've never had just a viewing
like a proper viewing
I know things about castor Troy and the
other guy but yeah I think I think if
you did like some type of self-aware
thing you know well I feel like that's
that's something if whatever you're
adapting or following up has some
element of cheesiness or humorous miss
about it I feel like yeah you can
redirect yeah come back to it and go
okay we get it we're gonna actually be
humorous cuz like if you look back at 21
Jump Street episodes I bet they're kind
of aged now and I bet that is part of
how they thought okay this will morph
really well and
it's kind of like a sci-fi idea of like
freaky it's like a sci-fi action idea of
like a Freaky Friday that's what they
thought is okay but then again I feel
like if you did face off as a comedy it
would just be a Freaky Friday never mind
you got completely can that those two
guys in Freaky Friday let me make that
Oh Jimmy freckles thanks buddy Dark
Crystal thoughts I'm planning on
starting that up because um we have Eric
horseman who was just in this chat
highly recommends it I've heard a lot of
people say that you don't need to have
watched the movie and some people have
actually said it's probably better if
you don't watch the movie
hmm I wonder why they say that I haven't
seen have you seen the movie ever seen
the movie yet no I'm just familiar with
it over there that was the corner I
didn't get much handsome growing up hmm
I don't
I got like Sesame Street and stuff like
that and like a few Muppets mmm I got a
lot of Manson oh yeah Richard Lenski
[Laughter]
okay let's see here yeah he moves a tad
Descartes Lovejoy hopes for Rises
Skywalker then it's a race parents
awesome I hope Rey's parents
[Laughter]
oh yeah we're ignoring Return of the
Jedi because they just announced you
that they're thinking of doing another
Texas Chainsaw that's a sequel to the
first one which they've already done
you've already went twice it's gonna be
the third direct sequel to number one
but yes they'll just start cherry
picking which sequel this this saw is
only a sequel to saw five but hopes rise
of Skywalker weight made that it's good
maybe it's maybe it was their parents
were Han and Leia and that's what that's
what kylo meant by your parents were
nobodies dicks I'll tell you that much
uncle I killed your dad
my hopes for it I see weirdly my hopes
for it is to not have too much hope
because I I have zero i I did watch
relative medias a resin Skywalker
predictions they had this great idea on
like this whole theory about time travel
or it sounded so quite really like they
might actually do that by my heart I try
not to get my hopes too I just I just
want to sit back and enjoy it cuz the
last jet being in this like movie circle
community like the last Jedi was the
movie very like talking about this this
is way out of town yeah it's like at
this point I just want to feel alright
walking into the theater because after
last Jedi started to become a thing room
yeah mostly I just want to have like
some kind of oh I'm happy to be seeing
the stars yes I I mix I am excited for
the movie yeah I am just also the big
deal but now it's a little more of a
nerve-wracking big deal yeah it's really
it's really just the the fan back I know
not everyone is this like hyper reactive
but that that voice that is very strong
will be felt and I feel like any movie
with phantom lends itself to that I feel
like Star Wars is a particularly hard
fanbase to really keep happy so I you
know what my hope is my hope is that I
don't see a rotten tomato score for at
least one week after watching the movie
I just want to watch it not here
audience score and just enjoy I just
enjoy them literally it's it's supposed
to be the thing is we know we're getting
more Star Wars maybe not yeah this may
be not a direct sequel of the episode 9
when I get an episode 10
however we know we're gonna get more
Star Wars so it would be different if we
was like no this is the last thing we
might not get another Star Wars
live-action thing for like 30 more years
you know it would be a different story
then you know what
truly want ya as is as troubles as
difficult as this process of finishing
the Skywalker saga has been I do realize
at least in this moment that this will
be as they say the finish of the
Skywalker saga and so all I really hope
is that they can bring it as some kind
of finish that feels finite and that
also feels within you know the spirit of
the stories yeah I want it just yeah I
don't know that's really vague oh I
wanted to end well but I don't know
there's so much to consider and there's
so many voices pulling these movies and
Star Wars is not as solid a machine as
Marvel so I just hope that they have
like a solid foundation and can just
stick their landing even if it's not
incredible just shrim
true Jimmy says thanks Jimmy again buddy
thank you how does it feel like we're
going to let Star Wars finish the way we
want to or we're going to fight till the
end and not I can yeah I I don't know
I'm very I think that's why it's easier
to get excited about the Mandalorian cuz
it could fail it'll be alright
they won't be alright but like I think I
think fandom would not be as strong if
that wasn't as good because it's just
one of those John Boehner I have a
request you left a comment about face
off - its it's a catchphrase it's like a
movie you got it you've got an epic
voice that somewhere on the next honest
trailer if you can but just anywhere
right the whole world's faces you I
can't do it whole world's faces are
missing I love this I've seen some
comments of when the question came in of
host arises come Patricia's is the best
hope you can have for it who here has
been in this this livestream since the
very beginning of the livestream
yeah who's an OG fan of the livestream
who's they
hey babies in the chat babies in the
chat babies in the chat oh BVS or Star
Wars more divided
I would say last-gen Oh the last shot is
for the very I would say last Jedi less
I thought I was more divided yeah cuz I
hear more people loved it to what they
see because BBS was a film that came out
with a lot of hate and then and then
there was a rise of defenders that's a
different story it's a good title
speaking of which did you guys hear that
the the Netflix shows of Marvel might be
going to FX my more about that in a
second but yeah I would definitely say
I'd definitely say last Jedi was more
divisive because that seemed to be a
[ __ ] battle for is it good or not
yeah and why is it okay to make it like
this and why is it not whereas BVS was
like no you know whatever we're not to
go I don't want to resurrect this
conversation yeah Carter Lovejoy thanks
buddy thank you so much do you think
they'll do a Harry Potter cursed child
film and get Dan a Radcliffe Emma Watson
and Rupert Grint and most of the
original gangster Harry Potter cast back
I don't want them to
that'll do it the Oh some people haven't
heard about this Marvel Netflix thing
let's answer cards question I'll tell
you all about it
yes damn that's a lot of posters I know
right there used to be a way more the
other way yeah so uh that's the play
right and everyone's freaked out because
it was black they did what cut it before
I laughed and then be like Craig's
racist I know what I think I don't think
they'll do a film what I think would be
cool as a surprise play where they're
playing them
I would like people to show up one night
that would be a charity like you
that would be I think that would be the
way to do it oh there was Carl up
shooting 7l meh I am practicing my nards
over on the fair isn't it wait when's
the raid isn't it like next week I just
love I love that area 51 right yeah yeah
I'm just running with your arms behind
you like this ladies every time they do
that in any anime tickles me Marvel
Netflix okay so here's what's going on
Disney owns Hulu FX shows go on Hulu so
what they're what's being talked about
right now is moving the Marvel Netflix
shows over to over - f yeah Netflix - FX
then and that way they can go up on Hulu
it's so dizzy still gets to work with it
and because the Disney Plus is very
adamant about not having r-rated like
content on the Disney Plus streaming
service they can get away with having
the show silico it's going up on FX or
Hulu which I think will be interesting
because you'd ultimately have to change
the format of each episode because
there's commercial breaks on FX and the
Netflix shows they designed those way
too long episode like way too much any
episode too many episodes of the season
and I feel like that if they like
tighten it down like 10 episodes for FX
because you'd have to do it in a way
where you could hook people into coming
back next week where as opposed to the
net when they run Netflix people just
binge it and then here you gotta write
it to a point where the AE I deal with
commercial breaks and B you got to write
it in a way where people will be
inclined to come back next week to
continue watching it so it would change
up the shows either way I be I just be
excited that the resurrected man that
would be the coolest thing in the world
right there what time is it John we got
to get going to a 10 all right guys
we're gonna leave in like two minutes
because I got a good going to add a
strip someone's a man-crush sexy AF who
said that lost lens for duck says that a
whole company and I agree I think Harry
Potter especially fantastic beasts would
make much better TV series than it has
made films mmm crows
knees and uncross somebody thinks you
look like markiplier this is look how
much little sleep I've got Carter you
can see these giant bags
Eric Horseman's back oh yeah I like now
straight to the point my friend you know
if you live in California Eric
dude I would I would be like aw she's so
gay so gay for you Eric make it gay
Eric's gay that's why I'm saying the gay
thing
Oh gene Jeter has gay I can't get some
sleep I'll fall asleep during ad astra
and then i'll just go around tomatoes
steal from the capsules and be like
that's my review I'll wake you up during
the space pirate he is saying literally
a whole bunch of things that Jeter's
here thoughts on Jimmy freckles again
thank you so much any thoughts on Eddie
M or the car oh yeah lead singer the
cars passed away rest in peace I mean oh
that should be a marketing campaign um
any em or the cars
yeah the lead cars the the frontman of
the cars the band the cars I thought he
was saying Eddie Murphy or the cars I
haven't heard about yeah Sean you take
this I mean that ants uh yeah I mean I
heard about this I admit I am NOT I know
like the cars like singles and stuff
that you would know I don't have like a
great knowledge of their deep cuts but
just the outpouring of love and stuff
that I've seen on social media whatnot
I'm pretty bummed to hear about it so
you know it seems like a great talent
and a warm guy his soul rest in peace
mmhmm yeah some cars now yeah yeah I
mean that's it always it's always sad
that it takes that but you know it's
time to get back into some music oh I
never lose your nerves guy something to
you know love you got alright guys we'll
never lose your nerd appreciate that
buddy we are gonna go there because we
have to catch a movie I'll watch Brad
Pitt we have to sit through 20 minutes
of trailers we want it we have to get
there I need to get some caffeine cuz
the plan is to shoot up the review right
when we get back yeah that hopefully
have time to edit it tomorrow yeah but
yeah anyway alright I'm losing all
senses I want to thank everyone who's
been here this throughout the whole
super chat thank you guys so much for
you guys this rock it's always fun to
chime in with you guys and also yeah
this whole chat and the super chat guys
thank you so much for your contributions
you guys are awesome
much love I will try and lucky keep a
look out for Saturday you might get a
Rambo review or an ad astra of you let's
find out alright see you guys peace be
with you lift up your hearts what comes
after that we lift them up to the Lord
let's give thanks to Lord our God is
right thanks and praise Judaism
[Music]